.
THAT PROMPTED THE WHITE HOUSE TO
STOP TAKING APPLICATIONS.
SO FAR NO DEBT HAS BEEN
CANCELLED.
>>> OVERNIGHT, PRESIDENT BIDEN
ROLLED OUT THE RED CARPET FOR
HIS FIRST STATE DINNER HOSTING
FRENCH PRESIDENT, EMMANUEL
MACRON AND HIS WIFE BRIDGETT.
>> TODAY WE'RE STILL UNITED BY
THE GREATEST OF CAUSES,
DEMOCRACY, LIBERTY, EQUALITY,
OPPORTUNITY AND FREEDOM.
WE STAND TOGETHER AGAINST
OPPRESSION AND INJUSTICE.
WE STICK UP FOR ONE ANOTHER IN
OUR DEMOCRATIC VALUES TO WHICH
WASHINGTON AND LAFAYETTE
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES.
>> LOOK AT THE FANCY FOLKS
THERE.
THE EVENT DRAWING BIG NAMES FROM
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY,
FASHION, POLITICS, BUSINESS.
HERE WITH ALL THE DETAILS CNN
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT KATE
BENNETT WHO WAS AT LAST NIGHT'S
BIG EVENT.
SHE PREVIEWED THE MENU YESTERDAY
AND NOW SHE'S GOING TO TELL US
WHAT IT WAS LIKE.
WHAT DID YOU SEE?
WHAT STOOD OUT TO YOU?
>> Reporter: WHEN THAT TOAST WAS
HAPPENING IT WAS ALMOST 10:00
P.M.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN TENDS TO NOT
RUN ON TIME, SO IT WAS A VERY
LATE EVENING.
IN FACT, PRESIDENT MACRON MADE A
JOKE SAYING I HOPE EVERYONE
ENJOYED THEIR DINNER AND NO ONE
WAS SERVED FIRST COURSE.
EARLIER IN THE EVENING JULIA
LOUISE DREYFUSS BROUGHT HER SON
AS HER DATE.
AND CHRISSY TIEGAN WAS THERE,
PREGNANT WITH THEIR THIRD CHILD.
AND JENNIFER GARLAND BROUGHT HER
DAUGHTER VIOLET.
ANA WINTER.
APPLICATION CEO TIM COOK WAS
THERE.
LOTS OF BUSINESS LEADERS WERE
THERE LAST NIGHT FOR SURE.
BUT CERTAINLY IT WAS MORE
STAR-STUDDED THAN WE'VE SEEN IN
RECENT YEARS.
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION WAS
NOT EXACTLY ALIGNED WITH MAIN
STREAM HOLLYWOOD.
SO IT WAS DEFINITELY A CHANGE.
ANOTHER CHANGE, MORE
POLITICIANS.
WE SAW ONE THERE.
THERE WERE REPUBLICANS AT THIS
DEMOCRATIC STATE DINNER.
KEVIN McCARTHY, SUSAN COLLINS,
STEVE SCALISE, AND, OF COURSE,
NANCY PELOSI WAS THERE.
THE OUTGOING SPEAKER.
SHE SAID SHE WAS HAPPY TO PASS
THE BATON THERE TO HAKEEM
JEFFRIES WHO IS REPLACING HER.
OVERALL, THE NIGHT WAS GREAT.
PEOPLE ENJOYED THEMSELVES.
THIS WAS THE FIRST BIDEN STATE
DINNER FOR THE ADMINISTRATION,
ABOUT 400 GUESTS WERE SEATED FOR
DINNER.
JOHN BAPTISTE PLAYED ON THE
PIANO.
BUT IT WAS CERTAINLY A VERY
FESTIVE EVENING.
YOU KNOW, GUESTS WERE FERRIED
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE DOWN TO THE
TENT IN HEATED TROLLIES.
IT WAS A LOVELY EVENING.
>> IT'S RARE FOR ONE TO NOT
HAPPEN THIS LONG.
COVID OBVIOUSLY DELAYED IT.
IT IS INTERESTING TO SEE KEVIN
McCARTHY THERE, PEOPLE MAY BE
WONDERING WHY HE WAS INVITED.
NOT USED TO SEEING KEVIN
McCARTHY AT THE WHITE HOUSE, BUT
HE ACTUALLY GOT ASKED ABOUT THE
GOP MAJORITY IN JANUARY AND THE
INVESTIGATIONS THEY PLAN TO
PURSUE, INCLUDING INTO PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S FAMILY.
>> Reporter: EXACTLY.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT THAT.
HE DIDN'T RESPOND.
HE SAID, I'M HERE WITH MY
MOTHER.
HE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS, KAITLAN, I
WAS INSIDE THE TENT DURING THE
TOAST HE AND HIS MOTHER WERE
SEATED TO THE FAR END OF ONE
TABLE.
HE DID NOT APPLAUD, CLAP DURING
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S TOAST.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS PROBABL